good morning John I want to tell you
about one of the coolest things I've
ever found out in my life it really
threw me for a loop and I want to throw
you for the same Loop so join me on the
journey when studying life on our planet
it is sometimes useful to think about
like how much the living matter of the
planet weighs on its own I'm this is
enough of this code on its own the idea
of living matter is pretty freaking
weird right living matter but that's
what we are and that matter has mass
like I have about 90 000 grams of living
matter or do I like not really most of
it's water like life couldn't exist
without it but it isn't really part of
the living system it's kind of just like
an ocean that I'm carrying around in a
sack with me everywhere I go so that I
can do the chemistry that is life what
the scientific establishment has decided
to do is just count the carbon which
makes sense I think that's a good way to
do it of course it's not perfectly
precise but it's precise enough we call
this biomass for example if you look at
the biomass of all mammals around a
third of it
human beings if that seems weird to you
it's going to be way weirder than that
that's like the least weird thing in the
video another third is cows just cows
now you might be thinking that leaves
the final third for wild mammals
I'm sorry no uh further 30 is the rest
of the Agricultural animals and four
percent four percent of mammal biomass
is wild mammals all of the whales and
elephants and skunks and armadillos and
shrews now is that the weirdest thing in
the video no it's not I used to think
when I heard this stat that this meant
that there used to be a hundred percent
wild mammals and now like 96 of them
have been replaced by agricultural
animals and humans that's not what
happened around a hundred thousand years
ago humans had a very tentative foothold
on the planet pretty insignificant
species in terms of biomass and at that
point wild mammal biomass was at its
peak but had been roughly the same for a
very long time it wasn't increasing it
wasn't decreasing it was quite stable
between 100 000 years ago and ten
thousand years ago human biomass changed
some but was still pretty insignificant
to ten thousand years but wild mammal
biomass dropped by like 25 a very big
very fast drop we call this the
quaternary megafauna Extinction it was
an Extinction event of almost entirely
very large mammals lots of debate about
this definitely a contributor to it uh
was human it's very tightly coincided
with the arrival of humans in North and
South America and then separately in
Australia what happens next is the very
weird part between 10 000 years ago and
100 years ago agriculture happens like
in a big way while the mammal biomass
Falls by a further third but the total
mammal biomass increases beyond what it
ever was purely because of humans and
livestock and now in the year 2022
humans by themselves represent three
times more biomass than all mammals
combined before humans we are heavy in
the last hundred thousand years there
has been an 85 percent decrease in the
wild mammal biomass and an 800 percent
increase in the total mammal biomass
throughout this video I've been trying
to not have any particular judgment
about whether the world should be the
way that it is just that it's
fascinating that it is the way that it
is but entering into our conclusion here
uh it's bad like it's bad to have an 85
decrease in Wild mammal biomass but it's
also very complex like the Earth is
absolutely hundred percent at its
historical maximum of complicated brains
I don't know if y'all caught this but a
few days ago some baby was born that was
the eight billionth person on the planet
I hope they at least got a certificate
so I don't really know what to say about
this except that obviously we need to be
doing all of this quite thoughtfully
because this is a very big and fast
change and I think that you can make the
case that we are actually doing it more
thoughtfully now than we were a hundred
years ago it's also really great to be
able to get coffee and socks delivered
to your door once a month and to know
that there are people working hard to
try and do that as thoughtfully as
possible coffee plantations can for
example lead to a lot of deforestation
but it can also be done in partnership
with a forest the small farmers who work
with the awesome coffee Club work hard
to decrease deforestation and to
practice regenerative agriculture the
stock club's closing Monday there will
not be another VLAN Brothers video
between now and then so if you want to
sign up you got to do it now the coffee
Club will remain open perpetually John
I'll see you on Tuesday